تقيم المخاطر المرتبطه بتسريب وثائق
السريه ومسؤولون يشتبهون في ان التسريبات
تم من مواطن امريكي
تظاهرات في السليمانيه احتجاجا على القصف
التركي ودعوات للحكومه العراقيه بموقف جاد
من انقره
في السودان احاله عناصر من الشرطه الى
القضاء بتهمه قتل اربعه محتاجين شاركوا في
مظاهرات سابقا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
سنبدا من الولايات المتحده التي تعمل على
تقييم اي مخاطر قد تترتب على امنها القومي
عن تسريب الوثائق السريه التي تتعلق بحسب
ما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه وقالت
المتحدثه باسم البنت صابرينا سينج ان
تعامنا يجري بين مختلف الوكالات لتقييم
تاثير تسريب هذه الوثائق المصوره على
الامن القومي لامريكا وعلى حلفائها
وشركائها
في غضون ذلك ذكرت مصادر وانا مسؤولين
امريكيين يبذلون جهودا حديثا لتحديد مصدر
تسريب الوثائق العسكريه
والمخابراتيه شديده السريه التي انتشرت
على الانترنت وقال خبراء امن ومسؤولون
امريكيون انهم يشتبهون في ان شخصا من
الولايات المتحده قد يكون وراء عمليه
التسريب ويرى هؤلاء المسؤولون ان اتساع
نطاق الموضوعات التي احتوت عليها الوثائق
تشير الى ان تسريب تم من احد المواطنين
الامريكيين وليس من الحلفاء وبهذا الصدد
اكد مايكل
المسؤول الكبير السابق في وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه للرويترز اكد ان التركيز الان
على ان هذا التسريب تم من امريكا لان
العديد من هذه الوثائق كان بحوزه واشنطن
فقط
ولفت مسؤولون امريكيون الى ان تحقيق ما
زال في بدايته غير مستبعدين احتماليه ان
يكون عناصر مؤيده لروسيا وراء التسريب
الذي ينظر اليه على انه من اخطر الخروقات
الامنيه منذ تسريبات موقع ويكيليكس في عام
الحكومه الفرنسيه صحه الانباء التي تحدثت
عن وجود جنود فرنسيين على الارض في
اوكرانيا ونقلت صحيفه لوموند عن مكتبي
وزير القوات المسلحه سيباستيان لكورنو ان
القوات الفرنسيه لا تشارك باي شكل في
العمليه الى جانب اوكرانيا وفي وقت سابق
كشفت صحيفه الامريكيه عن وثائق مسربه
تحدثت عن فرقه عسكريه لا تتجاوز المئه
جندي تتكون من عسكريين رسميين من دول
النيتو بمن فيهم فرنسا تقوم بمهاما قتاليه
ناشطه في اوكرانيا
من جانبهم قلق مسؤولون بكوريا الجنوبيه
انسول على علم بالتقارير الاعلاميه
المتعلقه بتسريب العديد من الوثائق
العسكريه الامريكيه السريه وتعتزم مناقشه
واشنطن في القضايا التي اثرتها التسريبات
وذكرت صحيفه نيويورك تايمز ان الوثائق
المسربه تحتوي على تفاصيل حول مناقشات
خاصه بين كبار المسؤولين في كوريا
الجنوبيه حول الضغط الامريكي على بلادهم
للمساعده في امداد اوكرانيا بالاسلحه
وقالت الصحيفه انسول وافقت على بيع قذائف
مدفعيه لمساعده واشنطن على تجديد مخزونها
مشدده على ضروره ان يكون المستخدم النهائي
هو الجيش الامريكي
الوثائق المسربه من البانتاجون تكشف
معطيات صادمه
توقل امريكي كبير في الجهاز العسكري
الروسي والاوكراني
[موسيقى]
الوثائق اظهرت قدره واشنطن على تحذير
اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط لها من
روسيا وتقييم اله الحرب الروسيه
الوثائق ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي المتهاوي
الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
وتكشف نقل المعلومات الحساسه الكياف
للدفاع عن نفسها من خلال تحديد توقيت
الضربات واهدافها
الوثائق تظهر ان عملاء واشنطن يخترقون
تقريبا كل الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
مسؤول استخباراتي غربي قال ان التسريب
مؤلم وقد يحد من تبادل المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان قوه الدفاع
الجوي تعمل على تعزيز امن حدودها الشماليه
الغربيه بعد انضمام فنلندا الى حلف الناتو
وقال قائد في قوه الدفاع الجوي انضمام
فنلندا الى النيتو واستعداد السويد للقيام
بخطوه مماثله هي خطوات تهد او هي خطوات
تهدد حدود روسيا
من جانبه قلم مؤسس قوات فاغنر الروسيه
بان اوكرانيا جمعت بين 200 الف الى 400
الف جندي للهجوم المضاد يبقيني
اكد بانه لا يجب الاستهانه بالهجوم
الاوكرانيه المضاد وباي تحرك يمكن ان
تنفذه للقوات الاوكرانيه في المرحله
المقبله
هذا وخرج انصار المعارضه الجورجيه في
مظاهرات امام البرلمان في العاصمه بليسي
ضد حياز الحكومه الجورجيه لروسيا كما رفع
المتظاهرون اعلام اوكرانيا والاتحاد
الاوروبي وطلبوا باطلاق سراح السجناء
السياسيين وبتطبيق الاصلاحات التي يدعو
اليها الاتحاد الاوروبي في جورجيا
خرجت مظاهرات في السليمانيه في اقليم
كردستان العراق احتجاجا على القصف التركي
على مطار المدينه وطلب المتظاهرون الحكومه
الاتحاديه بادانه انتهاك الاراضي في اقليم
كردستان واتخاذ موقف صارم تجاه الحكومه
التركيه
نحن كجماهير سليمانيه بشكل خاص وجماهير
اقليم كردستان بشكل عام نستنكر ونحتاج على
هاي التصرفات وهذه المعاملات اللا انسانيه
من قبل الحكومه التركيه بقصف مطار
سليمانيه الدوليه
كمباني كمبنى مدني لا عسكري ولا امني
لخدمي هنالك
يعني مقرات وسكنات عسكريه تركيه على اراضي
العراق واراضي اقليم كردستان لذلك يجب ان
يكون هنالك موقف جاد موقف صريح من جانب
الحكومه الاتحاديه تجاه هذه التدخلات
ووقفها
وادانتها
ويعني وضعت الدوله التركيه امام
المسؤوليتها في هذه المسائل باي حق يعني
دوله تركيا تهاجم على مطار مدني
فنطالب الشعب العراقي جميعا ونطالب مجلس
نواب العراقي وحكومه العراقيه اي الدوله
العراقيه باكملها الوقوف ضد كل هذه
الهجمات والعدوان الغاشمه على اراضي
العراقيه واراضي اقليم كردستان
في السودان امرت النيابه العامه باحاله
عناصر من الشرطه الى القضاء بتهمه قتل
اربعه محتجين شاركوا في مظاهرات خلال
السنوات الاربعه الماضيه واخد نقلت اعلام
محلي او نقل اعلام المحلي عن رئيس النيابه
المختصه بالنظر في دعاوى القتل
والانتهاكات الطاهر عبد الرحمن القول انه
جرى احاله قضايا المتهمين بعد اكتمال
اجراءات التحقيق وتوجيه اتهامات لهم بموجب
الماده 130 من القانون الجنائي الخاصه
بالقتل العمود
على صعيد اخر قال القائد في قوه دعم
السريع في السودان اللواء نور احمد ادم
القبه قال ان قياده الدعم السريع ملتزمه
بحمايه ودعم اهداف ثوره ديسمبر في انحاء
البلاد حيث دعا الى توحيد الكلمه والهدف
وتغليف مصلحه الوطن على المصالح الشخصيه
الضيقه في اشاره الى ضروره توافق الوطني
للخروج الى بر الامان وجاء هذا في وقت
انقلب فيه حزب الامه القوميه السوداني بان
العمليه السياسيه تقترب من نهايتها وان
العسكريين سيخرجون من الحكم
كشفت صحيفه بليتكو الامريكيه ان تلويح
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بمراجعه
علاقتها مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه
العام الماضي بعد قرار اوبك بلس تقليص
انتاج النفط لم ينفذ ابدا وانا تصريحات في
حينه كانت بسبب الحرج الامريكي من قرار
يومك
اكتوبر من عام 2022
امريكا اعلنت معارضتها للخطوه والسعوديه
مضت قدما فيها اتهامات للرياض بالوقوف في
صف بوتين وتهديدات امريكيه بمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه
وبينما كانت الولايات المتحده تراجع
علاقتها مع السعوديه كما تقول مضت المملكه
في طريق مصالحها الامنيه والاقتصاديه رؤيه
2030 للامير محمد بن سلمان تطلبت استقرارا
سياسيا السعوديه وايران اتفقتا على اعاده
العلاقات بوساطه الصين الرغبه في استقرار
سياسي بالمنطقه يقود الى نماء اقتصادي
وتامين خطوط امداداتها الى العالم
الصحيفه بوليتيك والامريكيه كشفت انه وبعد
مضي سته اشهر من التصريحات لمراجعه
العلاقات مع السعوديه لم يحدث شيء وان
حديث بايدن عن العواقب كان سببه فقط
الشعور بالحرج من خطوه اوبك بلس الصحيفه
اكدت ان اداره بايدن لا تستطيع الاستغناء
عن السعوديه وانها لم تجري اي مباحثات
جديه لمراجعه العلاقات معتبره ان زياره
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه غير
المعلنه للرياض جاءت في سياق استعاده
العلاقات القويه مع السعوديه
عشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
لا فيديو حذرونا من ان حكومته ستدمر
اسرائيل ويطالبه بسحب صلاحيه مانجفير
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
نفت الحكومه الاسرائيليه صحه المعلومات
التي جاءت في وثيقه مسربه نصبت لوزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه والتي تتحدث عن دعم
قياديين في الموساد للتظاهر وقال مكتب
رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو في بيان ان
تقرير كاذب ولا اساس له من الصحه الا ان
البيان لم ينفي صحه الوثيقه شكلا الا انه
شدد ايضا على بقاء المساد بعيدا عن اي
نشاط سياسي في غضون ذلك اكدت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه انها فتحت تحقيقا بخصوص الوثائق
المسربه التي تهدد امن البلاد
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايلابيد
طالب رئيس الوزراء بنيام نتنياهو بمصادرات
الصلاحيات المتعلقه بالحرم القدسي من
ايتامار بن جير واكد لابيد عقب لقاء جمعه
بنتنياهو انه يدعم اي اجراء امنيا قد تقدم
عليه اسرائيل ردا على الهجوم الصاروقي
الاخير وفي وقت لاحق اكد حزب ليكودا اختار
ممارسه تافهه في الوقت الذي تحارب فيه
اسرائيل على ثلاث جبهت
الجمهوريه لينزيغرام ان الولايات المتحده
يجب ان تنشر صواريخ كروز نوويه تطلق من
البحر في المحيط الهادئ لردع الصين واضاف
جراهام انه منفتح على ارسال قواتنا
امريكيه الى تايوان للدفاع عن الجزيره
قائلا ان الغموض الاستراتيجي لا يجدي نفعا
وفق تعبيره
مع تواصل صراع النفوذ بين واشنطن كشفت
تقارير غربيه عن مخاوف لدى الاداره
الامريكيه من اسلحه ذكاء الاصطناعي
الصينيه وسط تحضيرات من دخول هذه التقنيه
سباق التسلح بين طرفين
تحديات كثيره فرضتها اسلحه الذكاء
الاصطناعي بين الصين والولايات المتحده
والتي تنذر بمنافسه شرسه عنوانها الصداره
للاذكى الصناعيه فمع دخولي هذه الاسلحه في
سباق التسلح بين بكين و واشنطن والذي احدث
نقله نوعيه في الاستراتيجيه الحربيه
الصينيه على المستوى التكتيكي والعسكري
كشف تقرير صادر عن صحيفه الجارديان عن قلق
امريكي من ان تستخدم بكين هذه التقنيه في
السعي وراء السلطه لتحل محل الولايات
المتحده باعتبارها القوه العظمى للذكاء
الاصطناعي في العالم من خلال اسلحه تقنيه
يمكن الاعتماد عليها في الحروب المستقبليه
فالجيش الصيني يسعى لتعميم مفاهيم حرب
الالات الذكيه او حرب الروبوتات المقاتله
المؤهله لتنفيذ العديد من العمليات
العسكريه من خلال روبوتات ومعد صغيره
مجهزه بمدافع رشاشه ونظم رؤيه ليليه
وصواريخ واجهزه استشعار للقيام بالعديد من
المهمات في الخطوط الاماميه وفقا لمعظم
المقاييس التي تعتمد عليها مؤسسه السياسه
الخارجيه في واشنطن فان احتمال وصول الصين
الى الذكاء الاصطناعي العام قبل الولايات
المتحده يبدو وكانه تهديد وجودي للهيمنه
الامريكيه فالتحركات الصين التي تسعى
لتكون مركزا للابتكار في مجال اسلحه
الذكاء الاصطناعي بحلول 2030 يمكن ان تؤدي
الى سباق تسلح جديد تغذيه الاجيال القديمه
من التكنولوجيا وسط مخاوف تتعلق بالخيارات
السريعه التي تتخذها الاسلحه الذكيه من
دون تدخل بشري
قالت قناه فوكس نيوز ان مجلس النواب
الامريكيه يعمل على استدعاء رؤساء بنوك
وشركات للتحقيق بسجلات ماليه تخص هنتر
بايدن نجل الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
واشارت فوكس نيوز الى ان تحقيقات التي
ستجريها لجنه الرقابه في مجلس النواب
ستركز على سجلات نجل بايدن الماليه
لقي مها عفوا لقي مهاجران على الاقل
مصنعهما وفقد نحو 20 اخرين او 20 اخرون
بعد غرق قاربهم بين تونس وايطاليا بحسب ما
افادت منظمه ريسك الالمانيه غير الحكوميه
وقال احد المسؤولين في المنطقه في المنظمه
بان سفينه نادر رست في جزيره لامبيدوزا
الايطاليه بعد عمليه الانقاذ
وفي علم الدراما الخليجيه ظهر الفنان
الكبير ناصر القصبي مرتديا السوداني
ومستخدما العاميه السودانيه ليكسب قلوب
الشعب السوداني حيث اشتهر بشخصيه سودانيه
فريده عكس عكس من خلالها تعامل واخلاق
السودانيين والقضايا التي تهمهم في طاش
العوده كما فاجا ايضا الجمهور باسماء
ومعالم ومفردات موغله في العاميه
السودانيه
[موسيقى]
في الماده 82 قال بتسمح ليو ليه
كانت وما زالت الشخصيه السودانيه حاضره في
اجزاء سلسله الطاش اجاده النجم نصر القصبي
للعاميه السودانيه جعلت شخصيه الزول عثمان
التي يؤديها من الاقرب لقلوب السودانيين
بشكل كويس
ودي الشخصيه اللي نحن قاعدين نشوفها مثلا
في روايات الطيب صالح وقاعدين نشوفها في
في الشخصيات السودانيه المتقدمه يعني نحن
شفنا الانسان السوداني هو كبير الاخصائيين
وشفناه وهو مهندس كبير جدا وشفناه ومحاسب
واداء ارجع لامانتو لصدقه اتمنى اشوف
شخصيات ناصر القصبي في واحد من السماسره
اللي يجيدوا البيع والشراء لانه عنده حنكه
في الكلام جميله جدا
زين تقليدي يتميز به انسان شرقي السودان
ويعرف بالسديري اما الجلابيه فهي زي قومي
كما العمامه يرتديها الرجل السوداني في
مختلف المناسبات ناصر القصبي او الزرع
عثمان اصبح حديث شارع السوداني تعالوا مع
بعض نشوف اراء شارع
حافرجك على واحد من القصبي
اشتغل مع لانك
القرش ما بيطلع منك يا سلام كل يعني
المتفاجاه واكيد الشعب السوداني كلهم
متفيق زي كده انه نحن عندنا شخصيات كثيره
او عندنا جنسيات كثيره في السودان اجانب
ما بيطغرل ولا كلمه يعني زي ما هو اجاد
اللهجه حقتنا السودانيه دخل قلوبنا
باللهجه السودانيه اللي بيقدمها لنا كل
سنه وبعدين نظره بحاجه في الموسم ده لما
قاعد يقول لنا
حرم حرم ما ههه اكثر كلمه ضحكتك سنه اكثر
كلمه ضحكتني لما قالت عرفتها على وحده
الفيسبوك حبيتها وحنتزوج وحطينا جرس
حرفيا انا حسيت بس ده ده
الصح لانه يعني الشخصيه السودانيه صعبه
متابعوا ردود الافعال
العزاب شنو انتم
لا والله
ماما شافت وعد
وعدس تجننوه كده
اسكت
اسكت ساكت
والله والله
اموت والله ما ابقى ابوي
دقيقه زياده
[موسيقى]
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات